(soft upbeat music)
- I gotta have a baby now
everyone telling me
I gotta have a baby
I don't even know, like,
I don't if I have my
eggs work, I don't know.
I don't wanna have a baby.
But everybody is like,
you gotta hurry up,
'cause if you don't you be in
your 40's the baby is gonna
be handicapped,
and I'm like, well.
The baby's gonna have
to be handicapped
I don't know what to
tell you, I'm not.
First of all, I'm
gonna love dat baby
even if it's handicap,
I'm not an asshole,
I'm gonna love that baby.
(applauding)
Yeah, a 1,000%.
Plus, it's gonna come
with a handicap sticker
we can park wherever we want.
I'm just sayin' why
would I, I gotta go.
You guys were great,
thank you so much.
So sweet.
- [Announcer] One more time
for Yamaneika everybody,
one more time.
(applauding)
(upbeat music)
- Hi, Sir.
Hi.
Sir, hi, hello
Hello.
- Yes, Ma'am.
- Hi, how are you?
I just wanna make sure
you know where I'm going.
- Totally programmed
in the GPS right now.
Should be there in 22 minutes.
- OK, great.
Well the app said
that you're disabled,
so I just wanna make sure that--
- Ma'am, with all
due respect to you
I prefer the term,
hearing impaired.
And, I wouldn't take
pity on me Ma'am.
You're a 3.5 on
the app, I'm a 4.8.
I'm doing you a favor by
just driving you right now.
- Listen, okay, I'm not trying
to discriminate against you.
The app says that you're deaf,
and I need to make
sure you get me
to my destination on
time, I have a gig.
It's a The Stand, do you
know how to get there?
- Ma'am, if you look at your
profile on the app, you're
a known water bottle thief,
and a phone charger thief.
- Who are you the FBI?
Is this Blacklist,
what's going on?
- Sorry, what?
- I'm just trying to
help you out, Sir.
- I can't hear you, what?
- Oh don't play
that game with me.
- Can't hear you, I'm deaf.
- Don't fucking
play with me, Sir.
(applauding)
- Aw, Man, that's amazing.
Y'all ain't even heard
the shit I said yet.
I've been sittin
in the back, man,
listenin' to what you
guys been laughing at,
and I appreciate the
fact that you guys are
Progressive free thinking crowd.
That doesn't see color.
I'm black, ladies and gentlemen.
(laughing)
I just need you to
know that upfront,
or else my jokes
ain't going be funny.
(laughing)
Know what I'm saying?
Let's get that out of the way.
- Get me out, I want
out of this car.
This bus stop, I want out.
Okay, right here
at this bus stop.
- Ma'am you can't take the bus.
- Are you kidding me?
You're gonna tell me
I can't take the bus?
Rosa Park sat in the front
so I could take the bus.
- If you want to get
out, I can stop for me.
- Lemme outta this freaking car.
- Fine, you wanna
get out, get out!
I'm no longer responsible.
- [Yamaneika] Fuck
is wrong wichu?
- Oh my God. (laughing)
- [Woman] Like, don't
break the bench.
- Like for real.
Look at this old ass bitch.
Don't look at her, don't look
at her, don't look at her.
- [Woamn] I ain't lookin'
at no fucking bitch.
Stop lookin' at me.
- Would you like to sit down?
Please take my seat.
- Here we go.
- What are you doing?
- What?
- Why would you put
a stroller on a seat
like that, and this
woman's trying to sit down?
- The baby needed a seat.
- OK?
- He's in a seat,
he's in a stroller.
Why wouldn't you
give her a seat?
This is Harriet Tubman,
she fought for this.
- Why do you care so much,
you broke ass Beyonce'?
Beyonce'sang, she
didn't drink it all.
- OK?
- Real cute, I have diabetes.
- You know what's not cute?
That little camouflage
like people can't see you.
- We can see you.
- Who are you trying
to hide from, Candy?
- Stop it, you hood
rat, and you hood rat,
and Baby hood rat.
- Hood rat?
- [All] Wow.
- Bitch, if we're hood
rats, you're queen hood rat.
Look at yourself in a mirror.
- Look at that dusty ass wig.
You a mess girl, and
all three of the Tupacs
on my shirt is praying
for your edges.
How bout dat, ay?
- You not gonna help me
out, I did this for you.
Come on then.
- Fuck all y'all.
(women laughs)
- Girl, your momma fried you.
Okay how bout dat?
Ooh, look at this
little baby backpack.
- [Woman] Look at
that little backpack.
- Hike it up, hike it up.
Little baby backpack
full of Beefaroni.
- Taxi!
(screeching)
- I'm from the
South, and so I walk
on the outside of the sidewalk.
You all know this
chivalrous custom?
You know this, right?
That's to protect the woman
in case a car jumps the curb.
I'm strong, but I
ain't dat strong.
You know what I'm saying?
But I still walk on the outside,
because they're like, oh
Alzo, you're such a gentleman.
Little does the woman
know that the real reason
I walk on the outside
of the sidewalk is so
the juice from the
air conditioning won't
hit me in my face.
(laughing)
That shit is disgusting.
(dance music)
(applauding)
- [Announcer] One of
the hottest comics
working in New York City today.
Put your hands together
for Yamaneika Saunders.
(applauding)
- Thank you so much, Ron.
Give it up for Ron, right?
So funny.